look the gun is on the other side
it's right there
stay in the back
so listen um
i'm gonna try and come to you
okay
do you understand that martin i'm gonna
try and come to you
he's staring right at me the lion is
staring right at you oh my god why would
he do that
if i didn't know any better
i'd say i'm the bait
we gotta come get you man
if you stay by there you're gonna die
that up there
is the nundy pride yep it's named after
that magnificent matriarch in the middle
there wow yep and the males are okuda
and his brother
and we are we safe right here oh you're
safe you're safe they just finished off
last night's kill okay good yeah that is
insane
okay he's all right
he's just letting you know that he's
there
see the way it works with lions is the
females do the hunting the males protect
the pride we'll protect them from what
usually from other lions any lion from
outside the family comes into their
territory kuda and kawe will leap onto
it start ripping it apart limb from limb
or die trying
it's the law of the jungle
you